My swatch has given me so much information
that I can now use to plan
my hand knit blanket.
Nope, I'm not knitting
this one on the machine.
First, I don't have enough needles
and I don't want to knit panels.
Next, this is going to be a get-out-
of-the-studio project just for fun.
But the planning would be the same if I
was going to knit this on the machine.
I want my like it to be 50
inches wide and 72 inches long.
At my gauge, that means I need
to knit 250 stitches for 72 inches.
When hand knitting, we don't have
to count rows like in machine knitting.
And honestly, I'll probably
knit until I run out of yarn.
Speaking of running out of yarn,
my swatch is 6 inches by 7.5 inches and it weighs 18 grams.
I used the Knit It Now yarn
estimator and entered 6 by 7.5 and 18 grams.
To knit this blanket, 50 inches by 72
inches, I'll need about 1440 grams.
My yarn comes in 100-gram balls,
so the 15 that I bought
will be just right.
I'm planning a garter stitch border.
My swatch reminded me that the garter
stitch gauge is considerably wider
and shorter than my stitch pattern.
Can you see how the edge
dips on this side?
I just plan to block this
out so it isn't so noticeable.
This is just a blanket after all.
But the top and bottom borders
are really flaring out.
I've charted my 50-inch wide blanket
based on my stitch pattern gauge.
To prevent the garter edges from flaring
out, I'll cast on about
10% fewer stitches.
I'll knit the border,
and then I'll increase back up
to the required 250 stitches and continue
to knit my blanket in pattern.
When I get to within about two inches
of the finished length, I'll decrease
evenly across the row
and then finish the border
in garter stitch over 225 stitches.
By changing the stitch count,
I'll prevent this.
I'm kind of embarrassed to share this,
but as a new knitter many, many moons ago,
I didn't understand the relationship
between the seed stitch border and the
beautiful cable panels of this project.
Although this is a treasured family
heirloom, I cringe every
time I use this blanket.
Now, as I've been working with this stitch
pattern by hand, I realized that we
could knit this on the machine.
It's basically, a three
by three rib set up with the ribber.
Knit two rows, transfer stitches between
the beds, knit two rows, and continue.
For a smaller project, all those
transfers might not be too bad.
But that's for another day.
I need to get away from the studio and get
knitting on this promised
blanket for my granddaughter.